[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
who's ready
for two season two
of treason hunter
[Music]
this morning darth vader jr liz cheney
and the email lady hillary clinton are
living their best lives
holy actual [ __ ] did you see the
pictures did you see the pictures of the
frame time magazines oh my god
did you see that oh breaking [ __ ]
news
donald trump frames time magazine covers
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding he
stole top secret documents and he was
sprawled them out all over the [ __ ]
floor
he had him in his desk even steve ducey
understand of fox and friends even steve
ducey of fox and friends understands
that this is not defendable anymore
christie no man quite got the memo yet
there's a lot of them and haven't got
the memo i don't know if christina bob
has received a arrest warrant yet but
it's looking like it's coming
old bobsky is old she's [ __ ] oh baby
she is screwed
we're gonna talk about christina bob
today you goddamn right we are
i've been talking about it for a while
we've mentioned her several times on the
show
a lot of people don't know this but
christina bob was in the war room she
was actually one of the architects
of the eastman memo the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
the planning of it christina bob was
involved she was there with steve bannon
rudy giuliani and john eastman when
donald trump was trying to take away our
election trying to overthrow our
government and now
and now we find out that she signed and
said yes all these documents have been
returned no copies have been made
wrong answer
that's all [ __ ] my question is with
this picture that the doj has released
because it is it is very [ __ ] damn it
is very damning it's very damaging um
donald trump is absolutely [ __ ]
screwed here he is definitely gonna be
indicted and charged with crime it's
just a matter of how many charges will
actually pile on here i believe the uh
obstructive obstruction of justice is
one of the most provable ones i mean
obviously mishandling classified
information
but there's no better case to be made
here than the obstruction of justice no
no abstraction no collusion yeah okay go
with that one
although this morning uh grandpa
poopypants the former guy the cheeto
dust mobster is going with the dog ate
my homework
that's his defense this morning oh the
fbi boy they really made a mess in my
office with all those top secret
documents that i stole
and then i criminally criminally
obstructed justice by not giving him
back
they made a complete mess of that stuff
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
this is the if that is your best defense
if that's your best defense
that they took pictures of the mess you
made and you're gonna blame that the top
secret documents were strung out all
over the floor on them and that's your
best defense you are completely utterly
[ __ ]
now
the question is and i think this is a
very good question for the american
people to raise at this point
is when do they indict him
because it has to come there is no way
out of this he has forced the department
of justice to indict him here
he's forced it
how we might not even really know about
the raid and the extent of the raid
when they went to execute the search
warrant
to get back our documents their [ __ ]
hours
their hours [ __ ]
if he wouldn't have blasted it all over
his fraud social
and put out a big statement about how
they came in and stole his documents
they're not yours dummy
so he forced the doj into the situation
and now he forced him into the situation
of putting out there in the public for
the american the people to see that he's
a [ __ ] traitor i mean as if we needed
any more information jesus [ __ ]
christ
but there's a lot of dumb [ __ ] out
there that have no clue
about how much treason is being
committed by this [ __ ] fool
why why would you need why would you
need to steal top secret documents in
the first place
that include human assets that include
the most sensitive information
classified declassified it doesn't
matter
the most sensitive information there is
doesn't matter if you think you have the
magical power of waving your hands your
big mac stained hands over the [ __ ]
documents or not
and declassifying them with a
with this wave of your hand get the [ __ ]
out of here
that doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
and that's why the obstruction of
justice is so easy here
but i think the question is when did
they indict him he's really trying to
force them to indict him
i believe that's really the case here he
knew the jig was up when they went in
and executed a search warrant he knew
that [ __ ] was on the floor he knew that
[ __ ] was strung about he knew that [ __ ]
was in his [ __ ] desk like steve ducey
had to explain to christy gnome hey it's
a good idea to stop defending him that's
what steve ducey saying on fox and
friends this morning hey it's a it's a
really good idea to stop defending him
probably not a good idea this is getting
really really really shitty
and you people defending treason is
getting grosser and grosser
it's getting really gross
steve ducey even understands that
christy know him and she's a little
behind which not surprising
not surprising the corrupt lady who
tried to get her [ __ ] daughter a real
estate license who couldn't get a real
estate license and her state did
she used her power of the governorship
to
curry favor to her daughter hmm
you think she's okay with corruption or
not
of course she is
the question is when do they indict him
and i think that's a really good
question
i don't know
i mean i think the department of justice
had no choice but to go in and get these
[ __ ] documents
and the reason why is because they
probably have [ __ ] information that
they're still not they still can't show
the public
of who he gave these [ __ ] things to
and who he leaked these secrets to we
know he was talking about [ __ ]
emmanuel macron's ding-dong
he was spreading all kinds of top-secret
documents and top-secret information
about the french president's ding-dong
to his associates i don't know if he was
like doing it at his open mics that he
does at these [ __ ] weddings
and his golf courses where he goes up
and he [ __ ] complains to them about
how he he he lost the election i don't
know if he was like yeah and i know all
kinds of information about emmanuel
macron's ding-dong i have no idea
no clue if that's what he was saying or
if he was actually talking to people in
private conversations
don't know can't tell
but you think you think he's not he's
not talking about how emanuel chrome has
deviant sexual things in his past that
he can blackmail him with you think he's
not giving the [ __ ] documents to
saudis you think he's not giving them to
russians like a i don't know maybe a a a
ukrainian russian national
who is running around canada united
states
with fraudulent charities going to
mar-a-lago under under a [ __ ] false
name
taking pictures with donald trump who
knows
who knows
i think it's really funny that that that
russian spy story
she seemed like a russian spy to me i
don't know i guess we'll find out in due
time
seems like they're going to indict her
too they're investigating her maybe
that's what sparked this investigation
about the [ __ ] documents
one can only say
but the one thing we do know well the
one thing we do know is this
[ __ ] was obstructing justice 100
full stop there's
you don't have to question it anymore
it's right out there in the open doj is
showing it to you american people
i mean you can go further and say well
the declassification he stole documents
he had documents he wasn't had them
secure which all are crimes
all are crimes
but the obstruction of justice
is the one that the picture of the
documents which we'll show here on the
show i'm going to show you the [ __ ]
picture i'm gonna give you the rundown
on what the picture is and what i see in
the picture or and what you don't see
more importantly probably
but obstruction
no obstruction no collusion it's all
projection all of it all of it his
entire life his entire candidacy his
entire presidency his entire personality
is all projection even melania trump
this morning is deflecting
his projection
she's like no no no no my closets are in
a completely different part of the house
i have a separate bedroom i don't sleep
with that [ __ ] fat slob no way no how
i'm not anywhere near that son of a
[ __ ] and he does not come in my room he
does not come in my closet he's not
allowed there's a better lock on
melania's door for donald trump to get
in her [ __ ] bedroom than there was a
lock to lock up the top secret documents
think about that for a second
think about that
it is it was harder for donald trump to
get inside melania's room in her closet
than it was for a russian spy to get to
the top secret documents that donald
trump stole from our government
holy actual [ __ ] that's where we're at
that's where we're at
and christina bob cash patel and donald
trump have been obstructing justice
of federal crimes the doj not nora
not nora
the doj and really honestly
this dumb [ __ ] this dumb
[ __ ]
when nara came knocking asking for those
documents all this stupid son of a [ __ ]
had to do was pack up the [ __ ]
classified documents that he stole and
give them back to him
that's it they just he could have just
returned them to nara
that's all he had to do
and he would have been in the clear all
the crimes that he committed stealing
them harboring them using them for
whatever nefarious purpose he was going
to use them for
all that probably would have been skated
he would have do did what donald trump
has always done his entire [ __ ] life
got away with crooked crimes
but he can't stop criming folks
he can't stop
he won't stop
he's doing it today probably
i would imagine that he's eating right
now
he is eating top secret documents as we
speak to get rid of them so they don't
find them
so there's not more charges piled on top
of him actually you know what that's all
[ __ ] this guy thinks he's gonna get
away with it why do you think he's out
there [ __ ] posting on fraud social
freaking out posting cueing on [ __ ] i
mean he's trying to he's trying to stoke
to cast
stoke stochastic terrorism
he's trying to incite his craziest most
delusional supporters into committing
violence
because he thinks it'll scare the
country into making him king or some
dumb [ __ ] i mean jesus christ yesterday
he wanted to he wanted us to declare him
the president so he could pardon himself
from the crimes they're about to indict
him on
this is where we're at this is the
mindset of this [ __ ] man-child this
caged animal
and we still have people
not just normal average day people on
the interwebs not some rando in your
[ __ ] thread we're talking about
elected officials
who are being questioned by people on a
news network that support fascism
and placate to putin
on that channel in the morning show
where they have huge ratings
in that hour
the guy who is the head host of that
show looks at an elected republican
official and says hey
governor of of south dakota
probably a good idea to walk away from
this [ __ ]
probably a good idea that might be a
thing you want to do
christie gnome's like nope going balls
deep in it [ __ ] it
if we're gonna do treason let's do
treason right
and i mean we're gonna see these [ __ ]
boneheads march one after the other
today
in front of the cameras and on twitter
defending this [ __ ] [ __ ]
defending this treason that this [ __ ]
idiot has committed on our country
and they allowed it they [ __ ] allowed
it
they could have put a stop to this jesus
christ the first impeachment they could
have went to him after the state
certified the vote and said no you're
done mitch mcconnell the the bare
minimum he could do was go to the floor
of the senate and tell the truth that
they'd certify the votes and it's over
joe biden's the president dummy
they could have stopped it then they
could have [ __ ] impeached and removed
him after january 20th and sent him
packing
so much so that he couldn't have stole
these documents he didn't have time to
round up as much [ __ ] blackmail
on his enemies the enemy being the
united states of america by the way
yeah that's what he was [ __ ] doing
folks he that's what he always does
that's what he always [ __ ] does
that's what he's got over lindsay that's
what he's got over ron johnson that's
what he's got over rand paul cash patel
christina bob
rudy giuliani steve bannon it's all
[ __ ] blackmail
for the crimes and the corruption that
they have been a part of and committed
because that's the thing with this piece
of [ __ ]
you start to dip your toe in the water
with this [ __ ]
and then you start playing footsie with
him and the more you play footsie with
him the more he's got on you
and that's what the whole [ __ ]
shebang is here
that's why he stole this [ __ ]
he didn't steal this [ __ ] because he
thought it was a good idea for mementos
he probably doesn't even know what the
[ __ ] half this [ __ ] means
there's no way that donald trump can
comprehend that [ __ ] buffoon who does
not understand national security and has
no idea about national [ __ ] national
security and foreign policy no [ __ ]
way does that dumb [ __ ] buffoon have
any idea what these documents mean
what they could do that's why cash patel
is part of this cash patel is part of
this because cash patel had to tell them
which documents to [ __ ] steal
the ones that would be the best
blackmail in the united states of
america
that's why
that's why cash patel is freaking the
[ __ ] out
which he should be he's in big trouble
big [ __ ] trouble
because not only
does it seem like cash patel helped him
pick this [ __ ] out but he has implicated
himself by even saying out the public on
tv yep i was there when he was waving
his big mac stained hands over the
documents declassifying him as if that's
how it [ __ ] works
[ __ ]
you were helping him steal a
[ __ ] and you were helping
to commit treason by blackmailing the
united states if you don't understand
the [ __ ] post that the former guy the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
posted yesterday while two of them why
are people mean and make me the
president so i can pardon myself
or else
if you don't understand why he stole
those documents you're not paying
attention you're not [ __ ] paying
attention you know the most
disappointing thing this morning to me
is this isn't trending number one and
won't trend all [ __ ] weak
every american in this country every
person here whether you can vote or not
should have to look at that [ __ ]
picture and should have to know the
story
of the last president of the united
states committed [ __ ] treason [ __ ]
treasonous piece of [ __ ]
and we knew he would be
we knew he would be we yelled and
screamed this [ __ ] in 2016. hillary
stood on stage and said hey
this [ __ ] is going to cause a
lot of trouble he's going to be very bad
for our country and not just for our
country and our democracy but our
national security and people like
it's so funny
[ __ ] i talk to people personally that i
know in the last few days that voted for
that son of a [ __ ] in 2016.
and they're distancing themselves and i
said oh it's really cute that you
distance yourself now
we we should not
we should not let up in this country we
have to politicize this issue
play politics that's what that's what
they want to do that's what they want to
do with this they want to play politics
with it
tucker carlson lindsey graham
christie gnome
cash patel donald trump christina bob
all his [ __ ] stupid ass ambulance
chaser attorneys
they want to play politics with this
[ __ ] well let's do it [ __ ]
let's play the politics
let's win this [ __ ] they're giving us
every [ __ ] thing we need and if you
don't think that roe v wade
has everything to do with what is
happening down mar-a-lago it has
everything to do with it all of it it's
all trumpism
all of it is trumpism they [ __ ] hate
democracy they [ __ ] hate equality
they think that they're better than us
they think that they're a higher
supremacy than [ __ ] regular working
americans people of color
lgbtq they think they're above it all
even the [ __ ] law it doesn't apply to
them
that's what rose about
that's what rose about
is white men have more [ __ ] power
more supremacy than women
or other people in this country
we can make sure that you don't read
books we can make sure that you don't
get to identify who you want to identify
as we can make sure you don't get to
love who you want to love because we're
better than you and we're above the law
because we are the law that's how they
feel they're [ __ ] fascist
and if you don't see that connection
here
then you're not engaging in your
democracy appropriately so that is what
you have to do
because we get to indict the entire
republican party for treason this
november
we get to indict and convict the
entirety
of the republican party this november
it's up to you [ __ ] register
you register check your registration go
register other people
text call for candidates knock doors
whatever you can do if you got spare
change i don't care if you have digging
your [ __ ] couch you get it
give it to those campaigns give it to
pro-democracy speech outlets that aren't
both sides and [ __ ] i don't both sides
nothing [ __ ] them
because it is time in this
country to engage in our democracy and
indict and convict the entirety of the
republican party because they [ __ ]
deserve it
they [ __ ] deserved it they did this
to themselves we didn't do this to them
we didn't force donald trump to steal
those documents we didn't force him to
try to use those blackmail against the
united states of america we didn't force
those [ __ ] to try to overturn
our election in 2021 on january 6th we
didn't do that [ __ ] you [ __ ]
did
you [ __ ] traders you [ __ ] domestic
terrorists you goddamn america first
nazis not semi-fascists you're [ __ ]
nazis
you did that to yourself and now we get
to we get to in november as a country as
a democracy
to indict and convict you and send you
[ __ ] packing
ron johnson dr oz herschel walker ron
desantis marco rubio
greg abbott
blake masters
jd vance
just to name a [ __ ] view you're gone
[ __ ] you're done
all the way down to the [ __ ] dog
catcher we can get rid of these son of a
[ __ ]
they hate democracy
they [ __ ] hate it
and the reason why they hate it the
reason why they hate democracy the
reason why they hate law and order is
because it never works for them
because they don't get to run rough shot
over the rest of the country
so know this
know this
you have the shot you as americans you
as voters hell you as non-voters
even if you can't get registered in time
don't worry you still get to participate
in your democracy you still get to
engage that doesn't mean that doesn't
mean you can't make phone calls and text
that doesn't mean you can't show up to
campaign events
hell there's some people that don't have
citizen citizenship in this country and
they work hard they [ __ ] live here
they've been living here for a long time
i mean they deserve to vote but they can
certainly engage in our democracy
they're a voice they have the freedom of
speech let's do this [ __ ]
let's
indict and convict the entirety of the
republican party for tying their [ __ ]
ankles around this [ __ ] anchor this
treasonous [ __ ] anchor that is donald
trump
and hold them accountable
they're gonna be out there today folks
they're gonna be out there today
hailing oh they're gonna be they're
gonna be loving the type of treason that
trump committed
oh the fbi made a mess
of the top secret documents that he
criminally stole and he criminally
obstructed justice that for nara and doj
to get him back they made a mess of him
on the floor now they took pictures of
the mess on the floor
you don't have to put up with their
arguments anymore
you don't
and one more thing before we go to break
because we're gonna get to the shitless
roundup because oh my god
do we have so much stuff to show you
today on the tony michaels podcast
and we have so much [ __ ] to show you
we're gonna have to do like rapid
shitless roundup when we go through the
tweety tweets and trendy trends we're
just gonna have to hop one to the next
to the next to the next because it is
it's a big news day it's a big news week
but one more thing
the one thing that the department of
justice did and i believe that will
probably show through in the next few
days
is it boxed in this federal judge
whatever he has over this federal judge
whatever power trump has or thinks he
has over this person they really [ __ ]
boxed her in the stupidity that she even
played this game now maybe maybe she
knew that the department of justice had
the ability to do this and drop this
bomb
on this treasonous piece of [ __ ] and
make him [ __ ] just squirming [ __ ] in
his pants but i don't believe that i
believe she's a lackey i believe she's a
[ __ ] bonehead
and i believe she didn't fully
understand exactly what was happening
and the department of justice struck
they knew it
they knew this judge was not adequate to
handle the case that she is she is about
to blow up
but hopefully she does she knows that
now she has to do the right thing
she has to do the right thing
so we'll see what happens with this
entire case and i guess the question
today is when
when does this cold steel wrap around
the former guy's wrist
well we're gonna go through the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends as soon as
we get back from break don't go anywhere
we'll be right back with gabe sanchez my
co-host and the [ __ ] list roundup
right after these
messages we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
boy do we have a ton of tweety tweets to
round up today
we gotta surf the sweetie boosting the
training training cause there's just a
ton of ton of [ __ ] to round up the [ __ ]
last round up
listen we got a new a lot of new
listeners this morning i know there's a
lot of new listeners because of the huge
news that we have here gabe sanchez
it is unbelievable how many new
listeners we have today on the show
oh yeah
look at those trees and hands that you
get these trees and hands
oh my god this one
these hands were used to oh is that the
to uh
oh i see the magic documents yeah these
are the magic trees and hams these are
the magic trees so
we got a lot of new listeners here i
want them to explain to them how the
tony michaels podcast works we go
through the tweety tweets attorney
trends every single week day two hours
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific this is super
important for our democracy for you to
know exactly what the hell they're gonna
do what the hell they plan on doing
we've been trying to raise the alarm
bells for months and months and months
here you are you're in the right spot
if you are pro-democracy and you want to
make sure you engage in it you are not
just not just one hour
but two hours two
not not small hours either
big hours but big huge huge
new jailers
oh my god we got a ton of i mean this is
just
unbelievable this morning the uh amount
of news that has piled on um i don't
know what time it was last night when
they released this photo of uh of the
mess on the floor that the fbi made the
mess on the floor that the fbi made they
made they made such a mess uh no i wanna
i wanna say
it was kind of late last night when you
think when i when i texted you when i
was like oh boy yeah it didn't it didn't
seem very strategic it just seemed like
hey this is
and it's now time to drop this thing
like they yeah
i want to say they dropped it
around like
8 30 p.m pacific time right because i i
tweeted out the phone maybe that's kind
of prime that's kind of prime time so
maybe then maybe that maybe they dropped
it at that time uh intentionally you
know here's the thing is uh and we say
this all the time we have to politicize
every single
every single line item of all this [ __ ]
like
these people chris christie gnome had a
and we're gonna watch this video had a
lot of trouble this morning had a lot of
trouble this morning even steve
this is a treason step way too far like
yeah well the thing is like i just wanna
first off i just wanna say
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
big thanks huge thanks to donald trump
and every other [ __ ] republican who
said there's nothing there this is all
just a political move by the doj and the
fbi target trump we're planting evidence
they said
uh it wasn't anything important they
were just newspaper clippings they're
his documents his documents right
even liz harrington yesterday i think it
was yesterday she doubled down and she
said he
is the rightful owner or so
paraphrasing here she's he's the
rightful owner of these documents well
if we go back from from august 8th
it we had people outside with big ass
foam hats saying that it was the doj and
the fbi targeting trump and this is a
political hit the next day they were
saying that this stuff was
they started really diving into this
stuff was planted by the fbi there was
nothing there to begin with then they
started saying how oh he was just taking
the work home with him because he was
like every other hard-working american
in this country donald trump has never
worked a [ __ ] day in his life well i
mean i mean i mean he worked really hard
when he was in his big mac
classifying documents how many can fit
you know with the small hands he's like
he's like how many can i stuff in
in between the time magazine and don't
you don't you look at that picture and
think okay so he had all these frame
time magazine things do you think he
thought oh i'll just stick them in
between these frames and no one will
find them i have no that's got to be it
why is that box sitting there with all
these documents swung out if he didn't
stuff him in between those frames
potentially he could have stuck them
between the frames he could have put
them inside the frame you know how like
sometimes people like oh i hit a message
behind the photo oh this is like this is
like uh national treasure type [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah like
who is in that yeah well i've got a john
video to show you oh my god it aged
perfectly like he released it yesterday
and it aged so well but like i mean
yeah but quickly going back i just want
to say again thank you to donald trump
and all the republicans because if it
was not for them
and them challenging the doj and going
to merrick garland and saying you need
to resign christopher ray needs to
resign you guys planted evidence this is
[ __ ]
uh unseal the search warrant
unseal and red and unredact and and give
us the affidavit right give us this
thing friends parents let's see what it
is right
now how quickly they they switch gears
because they're like oh [ __ ]
not only is this a legitimate search
warrant in that there's an inventory of
items that uh we might not want to
double down on
they said okay fine you want to see this
thing cool here it is they released that
in a you know a somewhat unsealed uh you
know redacted form then they said well
we want to see the affidavit because we
want to know who the [ __ ] is coming for
trump and they're like well that's not
how it works one we never release an
affidavit but because it's such a high
profile public kind of situation we will
release some extent of it
what's funny about that though is that
the trump team never said that they
wanted it it was republicans it was fox
news it was these right-wing yeah and
trump right i mean trump is posting on
truth well right but he never formally
filed yeah
which they may not know how to formally
violence right right i mean their legal
team is
what is that they have no idea what
they're doing right you have elena
christina bob you've got another guy jim
trustee who literally was hired because
trump saw him on tv you think it's it's
because his last name is trustee he's
like oh he must be trustworthy his name
is trump you know he's like trust me i'm
jim trustee like that's what it is right
that's that you know he saw him on fox
news or some some other correspondent
kind of situation on news and he said
that guy right the other lawyer that he
has was was hired because it was a
referral from someone else never met the
guy never saw him barely talked to him
was like cool yeah we'll hire him so i
just want to say again thank you because
none of this would have come to light
right none of this stuff would have ever
been seen or shown to the public if it
were not for donald trump challenging
the doj claiming the fbi was planting
evidence and then and the republicans
doubling tripling quadrupling down on
that type of narrative right and the doj
was like okay fine we will release what
we can but i'm just warning you
the [ __ ] does not look good and so when
they released the the uh the attachments
yesterday on top of their 36
uh page uh respect response
they had the photo in there because they
were like look we're not making any of
this [ __ ] up here's a photo this is this
is the least damning photo that we can
show because we've had to cover up
because they were able to cover up stuff
right exactly they're able to cover up
today
i wanna i wanna i wanna uh
actually expand on this point because i
actually believe that this was donald
trump's intention because i think when
the when the fbi shows up at mar-a-lago
to come get the [ __ ] that they told him
that they did not have and he knew was
there because he's in betminster
remember this guy is not at mar-a-lago
when this happens
and he knows that all this [ __ ] is
laying on the floor he knows that shit's
in his desk he knows he's [ __ ] he
knows he's [ __ ] when that happens and
what he does is like they're going to
indict me they're going to indict me and
and i think he is his position was well
i'll make them do it before the midterm
and we'll make this a political chaos a
reality tv dumpster fire like he always
does so he's like miscalculation
well i mean
when doesn't he really right when
doesn't he make a huge miscalculation so
here we are in this moment but i want to
say
i would like to i'm with you i'd like to
thank all the republican the entire
america first nazi party out there
and all the treasonous pieces of [ __ ]
who participated in making sure the
entire the entirety of american people
knew exactly what is at stake in our
democracy for this election because we
have to get rid of trumpism but i do
want to apologize to someone here
i think the american people owe richard
nixon an apology i mean i know he was a
crook i know he was delusional i know he
did things
where he shouldn't have held the office
of the presidency of the united states
but for us to really demonize him for
decades and decades and decades as the
most criminal person who ever held the
office of presidency and there would
never be a bigger criminal i really
think
i really think we owe richard nixon
apology let's do this let's go to the
[ __ ] list roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and trendy trends
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the show we have reached
the part where we surfed the tweety
tweets and the training trends in the
[ __ ] listen round up the shitless round
up and boy do we have a lot of
[ __ ] to round up today what are you you
sent me a link here what what is here
it's a video but it's only 16 seconds
but i feel everyone will enjoy it as
much as i did oh okay well let's let's
take a look at uh what this is here
let's see if oh
funny
this is a cnn thing and gabe says i like
to thank donald trump for giving us the
funniest well [ __ ] the funniest and most
embarrassing 16 seconds in news history
let's see let's find out well i think my
volume numbers are good my volume levels
are good let's listen those who know her
tell cnn there would be nothing of
donald trump's in melania trump's living
quarters
not only do the couple have separate
bedrooms one person says melania would
quote never allow the former president
to store his items in her space okay so
i talked about this in the first hour
isn't it amazing that melania's bedroom
is more secure from donald trump
entering than those stops in those
top-secret documents oh yeah at
mar-a-lago she's like [ __ ] no i got six
locks there's a f there's binary codes
you you can't even drop in from an air
duct on a [ __ ] wire into my room that
room is vacuum sealed okay my jimmy
choos and my my dolce gabbana and all
these other things no one will be able
to touch it no one's gonna panty raid my
closet
okay do you think do you think this is
actually um a truth or do you think this
is more projection like she's like
i'm not i'm not guilty here if there was
[ __ ] in there what me that led him in
there to do it right i think that's what
it is
i think
whether
you know i don't know what they're i
mean it would it would seem to or appear
to be that they're obviously the
marriage is not on the best of uh
what would give you that idea yeah i
don't know i don't know maybe maybe the
uh
where she wraps his hand away and yeah
the numerous footage or photos or like
looks that she gives or she's like
you know she smiles at him
and then she turns and yeah she's got
that little
squint you know kind of uh face where
she's clearly not happy or at least it
would appear that way i don't know maybe
i'm wrong but would it make you happy if
you had to be married to that fat slob
though i mean really honestly no no no
no no i'm just checking what i'm saying
here is i don't think
that she you know i i obviously i don't
think she wants me in this uh
relationship or whatever i mean we had
heard you know last year or after or
after leaving the white house that she
was spending more time in new york with
baron trying to give him more of a
normal kind of living situation going to
school so on and so forth so it seemed
like there was a little bit maybe more
to it than that i mean this goes to show
that again like not the best of
relationship and i if i was married to a
guy
that maybe in my peripheral caught wind
that he had these documents and he was
under investigation i'd be like dude one
don't [ __ ] come near me i don't want
to be a social i'm still in this
marriage but do not come near me in
private
in public fine whatever but we can
pretend that we can pretend in public so
this might be an opportunity for her to
be like dude the source inside is her
like if melania telling them or it could
be some friend where she was like you
need to tell people that i never let him
in the closet i never let him near my
stuff i need to say
without a reasonable doubt i was never
involved in any of this so this might be
her attempt to distance herself
officially on the public record now that
trump and the republicans have forced
again the doj to show their hand and
they're not bluffing they said fine [ __ ]
it you you want it you want to see it
okay we will challenge this dumb ass
[ __ ] motion that you've done because
this makes no sense it's based on
frivolous legal theories
nothing of
substantial kind of uh of merit
now you could say that she's complicit
like yeah paula says on facebook that
yeah i mean she might she might know and
that is why she's like oh [ __ ] i should
i should distance myself i'm not saying
that she wasn't aware of it i'm just
saying that she actively took a role now
to say
nope not someone told me that i
shouldn't say anything i shouldn't be
involved and i think that's what's
happening right now is she knew about it
or at least knew to some extent and was
like
trying to distance herself here because
they did go through her closet they did
go in there so they had some cause of
concern that there might be something
maybe they found nothing right maybe
they found nothing in the underwear
drawer that is a possibility and they
found out that hey her underwear is way
more secure than these top-secrets
top-secret documents yeah i mean that
may be but what i what i do think here
is that and i've said this before that
it's a possibility that she's one of the
informants she's one of the ones that
was questioned by nara and doj
to know what the [ __ ] is going on and
maybe that's the reason why they went in
her closet in her bedroom that's all the
way across mar-a-lago apparently um is
because they wanted to make sure what
she was telling was the [ __ ] truth
right and and i think the other thing
too that is going to be um
really revealed here is because donald
trump is going to take this all the way
right
this is going to a trial folks now we
are ways out from a trial on this
particular issue i mean they have to
indict him they have to get a grand jury
to indict him if they don't already have
a sealed indictment already just waiting
for his dumb ass um they have to because
they we know there's other sealed
documents yeah that doj has well there
was others they were submitted last
night i think right so they have other
sealed documents that are sealed we know
they're sealed that are involved in this
case it could be a lot of different
things it could be more sealed evidence
that the judge only gets to see yeah
these could be uh sealed um witness
testimony right it could be witness
testimony it could be who the informants
are and what they inform again maybe
it's melania maybe it's the secret
service themselves i know texas paul
when he came on the show last week we
kind of talked about that and it made
sense to me i'm like man that makes
sense they haven't they have an oath to
enemies foreign and domestic and at this
point he's not the president they just
have they just had the duty to protect
him and they have the duty to protect
the country yeah and if this guy's
flinging [ __ ] top secret documents
all over the place he's putting him in
drawers he's he's [ __ ] he's using him
as napkins to clean up the big mac on
his [ __ ] face i mean i think that
this this justifies enemies foreign and
domestic at this point i know well i'm
i'm on the fence so like i know that
when texas back came on he said you know
uh he thinks a secret service which i i
don't i don't dismiss it i think that's
definitely a possibility the other one
was that it wouldn't be surprising
at all um and you know obviously mine
was i think it could be a family member
right someone who would have direct
access maybe someone who has something
to lose like melania right exactly you
know like it's one of those things where
it could i it could be one of those
because those are the only groups of
people that would be that close in
proximity to trump or the surrounding
kind of uh environments that he has the
other thing too is i mean
secret service might be more of a
possibility especially with tony ornato
leaving secret service
just the other announcing he was gonna
leave just the other day which is like
on top of all these things that were
like you know attacking cassidy
hutchinson saying that she was a liar
you know having uh the journalist peter
alexander
bite on that [ __ ] story about how
there were these sources within the
secret service who said that the story
was actually made up and captain he was
lying gabe likes pier alexander come on
yeah
don't be
peter alexander and i just want to be so
rough on it we are using air quotes
correctly on the show not like donald
trump on true social oh [ __ ] but
it's one of those things where it's like
it could be
it makes more of a case for a secret
service especially when you look at tony
ronato and he's like oh these people are
these secret servants are lawyering up
when questioned by the the gen 6
committee which is like why would you
need to do that if you're just telling
what happened on january 6 right all all
these text messages were removed from
january 6 and january 5th a little bit
sucks you're resigning even more sus
like what's going on
so more of a case for a secret service
seems to be making its way if you were
to tie this thing together but i mean we
really won't know
for a while right well and mayo makes a
good point here male is one of our
favorite on twitter she's watching on
twitch right now she says trump is done
and i think i think that's them
that's going to be the um
the narrative going forward and and it's
going to be really hard for these people
to unwrap themselves in this trumpism
but i think trump has done is
that that is straightforward yeah but
the problem is is that we have to unwind
all this stuff because we have the
january 6 stuff to unwind too oh they're
i guarantee and i believe this has to do
with some of the january 6 stuff oh i
think i think some of these documents
that live inside
um this treasure trove of stolen
classified information that this guy was
harboring and obstructing from justice
i believe the january 6 which we'll talk
more about
later on i mean i i don't doubt that
they would take an opportunity to drag
donald trump with all of this new
information that has come to light
they asked the doj and nara they're like
hey or actually i think they went
directly to nara they had to go to court
for the nara records right you remember
and so they're like nara can we get
these and they're like no
and we won't know anything more than
that
and so now we are learning exactly why
that's the case right we have a timeline
of communication back and forth of them
trying to get the stuff and them holding
or or
or delaying or stalling
on trump's side and then now knowing why
exactly they couldn't get that stuff
because this investigation
right and it's going to be hard to
prosecute this case because of all the
classified information so that's why
it's going to take a long time before we
actually see results here
uh in a conviction and an actual
sentence prison sentence for these
crimes but watch as christie gnome the
dumb [ __ ] governor of south dakota here
try try her best to tipton around
treason as as ducey on fox and friends
describes it i mean he puts it better
than almost anyone i've seen on fox news
could put it and she has a really tough
time leaping over it watch
well ultimately it comes down to why did
he have all that secret stuff
uh at mar-a-lago you know i know he his
team has said that they declassified it
but that's news to the agencies that
those documents belong to and and
governor he he had
he had apparently three classified
documents in his desk so there he is
he's like look look dummy yeah he's like
you can't you cannot ignore this anymore
this is a legitimate problem why did he
have this stuff and i was saying
his hands were on it
juicy like yeah that's the other thing
too is like why was it in the desk why
would he need that type of information
so close to him right right
and i will say ducey in the last like
two weeks since this whole thing kind of
came out of this this search and these
documents he's the only one asking the
questions right because brian kilmeade
will then jump over and be like oh well
you know like when he had jared kushner
on he was like oh well you know you you
you're fine you're like you're the
victim like you're you're being uh you
know improperly or unfairly treated
that it's funny to see the dynamic shift
now where he's like well i'm just gonna
ask what's on everyone's mind which is
why did he have him right why i mean
it's hard to avoid these questions
really and that's what's going to be
really hard um and and
it's not going to be hard to spot the
treasonous pieces of [ __ ] oh yeah that's
going to be the best part about all this
like you should you you out there
pro-democracy people should be super
excited about what's what's about to
happen in our body politic because
what's about to happen in our body
politic is you are going to be able to
politicize and point out every single
trees in this piece of [ __ ] like you're
going to be able to point them out and
say well they're they're for treason
they're i mean look at them they're
they're trying to justify the stealing
of top secret documents and and having
them available for russian spies who
infiltrate mar-a-lago but let's listen
to how the dumb [ __ ] south um dakota
governor christie gnome
decides to put it and then the stuff as
brian detailed on the floor it shows uh
five yellow folders marked top secret
and another one with that says secret
sci which means sensitive
compartmentalized information those are
the biggest secrets in the world
why would he and apparently the
president former president went through
him in january why wouldn't he say oh
you know what i really need to turn that
back over why do you before we get to
her i'm just i'm i'm actually astounded
by the ability for fox and friends to
actually lay out facts this is
incredible they've never been they
haven't been able to do this for like
five or six years to really come out a
it might be time to rebrand the show at
least for the next period of time to be
facts and friends oh my god let's listen
have all that stuff at mar-a-lago
well that's why i think it's important
that this is transparent and that we do
have someone who's outside of the doj
looking at this and talking to people
what what is this information
no dummy this is what the doj does is
they prosecute crimes that is what they
do this is the agency that does the
thing you're describing
this is the agency that we have you're
just upset that now this agency has got
your deity against the [ __ ] wall here
yeah and he's about he's about to get
had that's the only reason i mean that's
that's the thing it really is they
again they have you know double triple
quadruple down on this idea that nothing
that trump took was of national security
it was nothing more than newspaper
clippers and photos and documents that
he owned that he was the rightful owner
of right
they keep challenging
and they keep [ __ ] losing
and you would think at a certain point
that
considering how easily republicans can
switch gears and say well i never said
that [ __ ] that's mainstream media that's
fake news right that's what they've done
before in the past because they learned
from people like trump who was their
deity their [ __ ] golden golden statue
calf that they have at the [ __ ] cpac
but you you look at this and it's like
they're just gonna keep going with it
because maybe they believe at some point
they will find something that's like oh
see we told you about that one thing was
true so everything's true yeah okay well
i mean
this is this is not going well for them
and it doesn't go well for her here
because watch watch as she tries to make
sense of this that the doj actually is
the department of agency that
investigates crimes we don't know what
was in there we don't yeah we do i think
well yeah they do declassified all this
information it doesn't matter let's find
out really what the process is what is
wrong we know what the process is yep we
know that they're present
it doesn't
matter governor i don't think any
president has ever carted off that many
documents boom
their house after they left the
presidency oh oh
oh
you know that you know that [ __ ] gift
we're like
oh the savage one yeah yeah yeah we
should put that on there that's it we
should do this a little bit we need to
redo this a little bit
it is it is very
uh surprising to see ducey ask these
questions or point out the facts of like
he had these documents he had many
documents he why would he need that many
documents and it's not only like oh he
had documents it was like why does he
need [ __ ] sei documents right secret
human intel documents classified
documents why would he need government
documents in his desk so close to him
when he doesn't get security briefs
because we're like we can't trust him
anymore we need to cut that off
thank god
and then they were like oh well uh he
just you know like coming up with an
excuse now they they've already run
through i think i don't know seven or
eight excuses but between obama did the
same thing which is incorrect
uh he took it home with him he was
hard-working he accidentally packed
all of those [ __ ] documents in boxes
by mistake
uh it was planted
uh it was the dog ate it the dog ate it
the dog i guarantee that's gonna be one
that comes up soon enough but they
they've run they keep running through i
mean they're gonna start cycling through
these they got it yeah they got to
recycle this [ __ ] because they can't
come up with a better excuse i mean you
if you want to see a dead body here's a
dead body of in this case um midas touch
retweeted the video um uh yesterday of
ted cruz from lauren windsor
where she got him to say yes
they need to deep on the mpi
and of course
midas touch just points out the fact ted
cruz wants to deep on the fbi he said it
he
said it he said it and here
here's ted cruz this is hilarious and
again we got a lot of midas mighty here
so you'll love this you'll love this
exchange here
ted cruz says to to midas touch after
they just say what he said on video
he says lefty twitter is gonna lie
what lie about what you literally on
video of you saying it what are you
talking about you piece of [ __ ] he says
it's what they do
but every word i said is true
okay so you either said it
or you didn't say it you [ __ ] dummy
he says the fbi's rate is a horrific
abuse of power again
not knowing what your reports mean abuse
so it's not an abusive power right
right i mean if he's using air quotes
here which i don't know if he's using
air quotes but i don't know who he's
quoting if he is he quoting himself i
don't know if he's quoting himself if
he's courting the former guy i'm not
really sure i think it's air quotes
which is the inappropriate way to use
these quotes but then he says there
needs to be quote air quote a complete
house cleaning which that would be the
opposite if it's and maybe he's quoting
the former guy here i don't know at the
fbi and then he says we need to quote
real oh we need
real oversight why is he putting these
things in close why i don't know it
needs to be a complete house cleaning we
need a real oversight because when you
add quotes i think he's quoting himself
i think he's quoting himself weird
because why would you need to quote
yourself right here's a full quote right
well and here's the thing he says all
absolutely true number one
there is real oversight from congress
they actually have the they have the
ability of oversight of department of
justice that is the thing they have
right they the uh raid is not a abusive
abuse of power if they have a [ __ ]
federal judge who signs off on a goddamn
search warrant and they execute the
search warrant the way that it says the
way that they did who who saw and read
over the affidavit to say okay you
actually have
evidence of wrongdoing or a crime being
committed or was committed so i will
sign off on this search warrant making
it legally
in your right
to go through and search the premises of
mar-a-lago and he says they need a
complete house killing which apparently
they're doing house cleaning at these
law enforcement these law enforcement
agencies like the fbi apparently the the
fbi agent who's responsible for pushing
this stupid [ __ ] hunter by the laptop
story apparently resigns that's the the
fbi agent that trump was trying to say
resign because of the search warrant
it's not it's because of some [ __ ]
fbi agent who's pushing some hunter
biden laptop story inside the agency so
there is house cleaning happening even
like you pointed out not the fbi but
secret service tony ornato gone right he
resigned also a complete house clean
okay this is what's funny about this
argument right here but this is there
needs to be a complete house clean at
the fbi okay fine so you're now saying
that there needs to be a redistribution
of funds and resources and allocating
certain talent or or personnel to
certain areas
much like what is under the like defund
the police right kind of right message
right which is actual which defund the
police defunded by is a horrible way to
frame the actual message right right
because that's
again i talk about all time we should
politicize everything and it's not about
what you say it's how you say it right
and then but if you say something a
certain way and people pay attention but
you're saying it the wrong way then
everyone's paying attention to it the
wrong way and that's what ted cruz is
pissed off about here is that midas
touch is pointing out that he wants to
defund the fbi right
they're mad they're mad at the messaging
against them and here's what i said
because really this was yesterday when
he said all this [ __ ] which all this
[ __ ]
this morning with these [ __ ] pictures
abuse of power complete house cleaning
and oversight you're a [ __ ] idiot i
said that that aged well traitor and i
quote tweeted i ain't [ __ ] screenshot
i'd quote tweeted some [ __ ] and i
called him a [ __ ] trader [ __ ] that
guy [ __ ] him well
it's also it's also you know
people like margie taylor green ted cruz
uh josh hawley like all these people are
demanding the resignation of christopher
wray who's a republican who was
appointed uh by trump you've got you
know merrick garland who is a
very calculated not going to try to
misstep has experience isn't his first
rodeo type of person
um these are people who are
pro-democracy these are people who want
to do the right thing they want to
make sure that in their position their
their their role they actually go
through
and follow the rule of law
and these people like ted cruz donald
trump josh hawley margaret taylor green
or rand paul any of these people do not
want that they want resources and
funding to be cut from these agencies so
that they don't have the ability to
investigate them it's like it seems very
weird why now all of a sudden because
margie taylor green she's pro-law
enforcement as soon as she gets doxxed
and they have to come to her house she's
like i want to thank everyone who was
involved that made sure that i was safe
so you want to deep on the fbi but you
want to fund the law enforcement but you
want to defund all like it doesn't make
any sense and it's like this this
hypocritical back and forth choose a
lane type thing
that is the republican party and you saw
it throughout all of this on the search
it's like unseal it seal it redact it
unredacted don't show it show it file
the motion wait don't file the motion
it's [ __ ] insane it's hard to keep up
with because so much has changed in
three weeks but [ __ ] man well i mean
speaking of manga republicans
do you know what manga stands for now do
you know
let's listen let's listen it's it's
changing as we go here it's kind of like
a fluid movement but let's listen as a
friend of mine uh professor
murray has said maga can also mean
making attorneys get attorneys
i'm making attorneys
get attorneys holy [ __ ]
this is this is crazy because i want to
talk about um
christina bob here because really oh boy
that's a huge part of her and elena
[ __ ]
and one of the biggest reasons why is
because
she appears to be that she signed off
to say that not only did they not make
copies of these things but all the stuff
that they wanted was returned and she
guaranteed it which
again i'm not sure exactly how donald
trump gets these [ __ ] people to do
this and maybe we get michael cohen on
to describe it because he's actually
talked about it before we're like he's
just showing the water
he's like
well yeah that's right they quoted a
quote in terms of the actual process
they because they in the for this is for
the special masters what you're right
right yeah and they're like look you
want two weeks or you waited two weeks
to request this thing you bring that up
can you bring that yeah yeah and i'll
bring it up on screen we'll talk about
it because here i have um
um of course this uh tweet here
um
but it shows here this is the um
this is a certification and of course
down down below is redacted and that's
believed to be christina bob's um
signature and i think in this
30 was it 37 or 38 page 36 pages because
they had 40 and they only use like 36 of
them and we don't really need we don't
need 40 to show you with the treason
that this guy was committing
um
but this is the cust uh the
designated person for custody of records
for the office of donald j trump and the
certification that uh based if you look
at number three here let me see if i can
zoom in here based on the information
that has been provided to me
um which is very important in that
wording
on behalf of the office of donald j
trump a diligent search was conducted a
boxes that were moved from the white
house to florida which now we know that
that's a [ __ ] lie yeah and whoever
signed this thing is in big [ __ ]
trouble yeah my guess is it's probably
christina bob because here's the picture
folks here's the here will be the
historic picture that you will refer to
um in in the decades to come
when when we talk about it again what
it's like for a united states president
to go to prison this is the picture that
you were referred to no one had to see
this the public did not have to see this
it was republicans technically people
really can't see a lot of it no no no
but it's the idea that this [ __ ] was
just right like
what they did was they were like all
right cool uh we're taking it from the
office and we're gonna put on the ground
here's a measuring so you know the size
here's the you know 2a to show that this
is the evidence that we collected here
that is i mean also like i feel like the
time
uh
the the we were talking about earlier i
feel like that was just in a box that
was just sitting there on the ground i
don't think that they put that in there
that at least i believe because
there's nothing that probably of
evidence that i would unless
there's possible they have a lot more
pictures of this
for sure this is just one this is two
which means there's a 1a and there's
going to be a 3a a 4a if you know
there's going to be right
because remember there's a list of
evidence that has been redacted there's
a list of the actual you know uh uh
inventory that parts have been redacted
this is stuff that's with within those
184 documents
um but they probably you know i can't
well who knows this might have been on
the ground i highly doubt it i'm sure it
was on the desk or near the desk and i
think it was in between these [ __ ]
these time magazine frames i i think
that's what that box is sitting there
for
that's what and i think they got that in
the frame the picture shot the frame
shot there to show that hey this is
where we found them because there's
probably a another picture showing them
in between the frames
and that's i mean
that's why it's so important that this
this statement diligent search was not
done they didn't look they didn't look
in the way i mean that's the thing it's
like when you're known or when you are
shown to have lied in that context to
say like
hey guys we took all the time and
resources to really look for the stuff
and we only found a handful of documents
and they're like okay are you sure about
that and then they go back and forth and
back and forth like okay here's the you
know 15 boxes or whatever
um
but you know they signed that that piece
of paper that said we
legally
agree and tell you that we are that this
is the truth we do not have any more we
gave you everything that's possible
and then when they finally go through it
they're like we don't think we have
everything and like no you have
everything you ha you have everything
guys you have it believe trust me trust
me i'm jim trustee right right and then
it's like nope actually we're going to
go and get i don't think
we're going to do well you know we've
been raising the alarm bells about
christina bob here because someone's
always in the chat ringing alarm bells
about christina bob and here she tweets
christina bob aka former executive
secretary for the department of homeland
security turned o-a-n-n propaganda
pusher and arizona fraud
fraud at fundraiser and grifter pushing
the big line to overturn the election
and undermined democracy hence dominion
is suing her alarming you should be
because she was
christina bob
not only is she was she the executive
secretary of department homeland
security during the 2020 election she
left to go be a propagandist over at oan
for donald trump to push his [ __ ]
lies about the pandemic and his election
and election fraud and mail-in ballots
but she was in the war room when they
were trying to overturn our election and
steal our government away from us with
rudy giuliani steve bannon and john
eastman the other thing too that this
[ __ ] [ __ ] did and yes i don't use
that word a lot but i am gonna use it
here that she did what she she used her
ability and insider
inside with trump to help john eastman
construct the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
blueprint lay out the plan of the
special electors and that is why she's
still defending him gabe she's not
defending him because she thinks it's a
good idea or she thinks she's gonna get
away with it she's got criminal
liability all over the place here and
donald trump could turn on her in a
[ __ ] minute and she knows it that's
why she's willing to commit more crime
for this [ __ ] and that's what's
happening here and of course christina
bob
is a [ __ ] trader and she is a danger
to our national security she was an
executive secretary of the department of
homeland security
she knows what classified documents are
she would know when she saw one what the
[ __ ] it was and the importance of why
this is sitting in his desk drawer are
in between the time magazine frames in a
box sitting on the [ __ ] desk where a
bunch of russian spies are coming in
that infiltrate mar-a-lago pretending to
be a rock child she knows that yeah she
[ __ ] knows it and she should be held
accountable for it i think she's going
to be so
good luck to christina bob she's yeah
well you know she's an attorney who
needs to get an attorney oh no her and
elena right like you know oh my god that
team
of misfit incompetent lawyers
are struggling because what's happening
is they have they have made it they have
made a statement they have accused right
through suggesting or even outright
saying like we don't know if the fbi
didn't plant that stuff how do we know
these documents were planted right right
calling into question the legitimacy of
the fbi which then caused other people
like margaret taylor green to say we
need to defund the fbi
but when you have an attorney who is
outright lying
for various things that have been that
have been debunked so far
it comes in a question like is the
is the bar association gonna gonna take
away a license to practice law because
this seems like a pretty big
detrimental kind of accusation to make
or or uh um
or disinformation to spread
that you willingly know
and you decide that you're going to
say the lie say the opposite of the
truth
and and spread that and be disproven on
multiple occasions right you would think
that it was like all right i'm sure
she's been reported and i guarantee the
bar station's like ah [ __ ] man
like how did we how did we give this
person the ability to practice law right
either these two people but they're on
the record they're on fox news oan
newsmax they're saying it they're like
oh this is just a political hit against
trump and this stuff was planted how do
we know the stuff wasn't planted by the
fbi this stuff was probably planted they
didn't get to watch the the
search that happened despite the fact
that the trump family was watching the
search live right can you point out um
the time or the date stamp here on
katelyn's tweet about this that i just
read can you point that out
november oh
wait what two thousand oh twenty
one
she's always in the comments warning us
about christina bob and i she was
absolutely dead honestly that's almost a
year ago that's like wow
nine months ago whoosh yeah been all
over that trees in this piece of [ __ ]
for a while whoa
oh yeah yeah this is i mean she's good
she's good she knows it well i mean
chris and when i say that i mean i mean
kailyn kailyn's good she knows it well
because christina bob has been all over
oan and she's been all over the place
but she showed up
in that in the room
in the room
with steve bannon with rudy giuliani
with john eastman when they were trying
to overthrow the government and i'm
going to get back to this but i want to
i want to take one more
time to tell everyone who christina bob
is because that's one thing we do here
on the tony michael's podcast game every
single weekday two hours is go through
to show you who these [ __ ] are
and like texas paul said yesterday you
have to listen to them when they tell
you who they are you have to listen
they're telling you who they are listen
to this treasonous piece of [ __ ]
describe this is when they were in
alaska for their little alaskan treason
tour listen to her describe how she's
gonna steal the maga trump train is
going to steal away our vote in our
government listen evidence that joe
biden's cheated so they could withdraw
their electors or they could actually
decide to award trump electors although
i would anticipate they would probably
just withdraw the electors and if that
happens from three different states
three different resolutions go into
congress and i'm sorry i'm summarizing
this it's a complicated issue but i
would have to go in it's not it's not
complicated it's not complicated it's
done it's over it's certified we we are
we are beyond the 2020 election you
cannot overturn it you cannot overwrite
it it is done christina bob and by you
pushing this narrative anywhere you are
a [ __ ] traitor yeah you're a traitor
that's it bottom line period that's
enough we do not need to hear from you
anymore besides in a courtroom when
you're indicted on federal charges but
that's also the tactic used by
republicans is they love to rewrite
history they love to be revisionist they
love to say
that's not actually how it went down
right that's why republicans are so
afraid that we actually include
historical facts in our textbooks to say
like oh yeah the white guy columbus and
all these other people that came through
actually weren't great in slavery it was
actually [ __ ] terrible and they're
like oh no no no no sensitive ears we
don't we don't want to hear that stuff
it makes us feel guilty
is she in front of a green screen here
this is i believe from trader news
network i believe she is in front of a
green screen uh just because the
background is darker and her face it
says jupiter florida up here at the top
but i don't know what the [ __ ] jupiter i
mean maybe obviously maybe she is in
florida but she's definitely in front of
a green screen here well she's
definitely on another planet possibly
jupiter like the fact that they want to
make these legal accusations oh my god
is
idiotic
absolutely [ __ ] out of their minds
okay let's listen to her on the trader
news network i'm not going to give up on
this [ __ ] [ __ ] as i called her
earlier i don't use that word a lot but
this is appropriate here
uh i i don't think that there was
actually anything there that's
worthwhile i will see what they come up
with you know if they did it'll be
interesting especially since they
precluded me from actually watching what
they did
but but at this point i don't
necessarily think that they would even
go to the extent of trying to plant
information i think they just make stuff
up
and i would you know come up with
whatever they want and i that's the way
that they will have to proceed in order
to actually try to indict the president
because they they don't have anything
there there's just nothing there
so she's saying she's saying that it
didn't want to indict him to actually
get him and say you're there's a crime
they have to plant evidence that's what
she's saying right there the only way to
legitimately get trump and indict him is
to plant evidence which is like i don't
think they would go that far but the
only way that i could see them getting
him behind bars or [ __ ] you know uh
uh some some metal bracelets
is to plan evidence
right well that is that statement
that statement did not
did not age well it just did not age
well you would think you would think if
you're gonna go on tv because you
probably have i would hope as a lawyer
you have some insight into what was at
mar-a-lago maybe you're just going off
the good will of listening to what trump
has to tell you when you say hey was
there actually anything here and trump
goes no nothing it was mine was
declassified it was mine nothing's wrong
it's okay it's just a big
misunderstanding
when you hear that and she goes okay
cool don't have to question you i'm now
going to double down on this idea that
there was nothing
nothing bad in your office there was
they found nothing bad right because
if she had actually watched this i
wonder if she would have changed her
message in this interview
if she had actually seen
the sci documents classified top secret
documents all these government things
that trump should not have had if she
would have actually seen it
i kind of think hopefully that she would
have changed her tune to be like uh
this is an unfair treatment of trump and
then probably just cut it off there and
not gone to
the fbi had to plan evidence
well i mean but they always over
calculate they always think that this
[ __ ] idiot's going to get out of
trouble i mean that's that's exactly
over calculate they don't calculate well
that's true well i mean you know they're
they're they're miscalculating let's say
yeah i mean even even michael cohen even
michael cohen has has admitted in front
of congress that he miscalculated with
trump that that it was always this this
game when you play ftse with him and he
actually shows up again
um in this in this and on page 20 here
yeah but you should go up to the top
part to give context to why they mention
him okay so it says finally the fact
that the former president filed this
motion two weeks after the search
occurred
and only just affected service on the
united states on august 29th
quote
uh
little gates against a finding of
irreparable harm
down at the bottom they describe for an
example
this is hilarious for example after fb
because what they're doing is he's
saying i want a special master yeah this
has to do with the special master and
what he wants is someone who he has
control over to look at this stuff
because what he wants them to do is pick
it out that's what he wants him to do
right he wants him to pick it out and
not use it as evidence so it can't be
criminally used against it yeah yeah and
it's privileged which he doesn't have a
privilege um and nor does he own these
documents because so there's nothing
that a special master would pick out now
at the bottom it says for example after
fbi agents executed search wardens
warrants on april 9th
2018
so this is an example going back several
years
at various properties belonging to
michael cohen
who had served as private counsel to
then president trump
and we all remember this when michael
cohen was raided
it says cohen's council sent a letter
on they even put it in italics so you
yeah they know that emphasis is on the
same day on the exact same day
um to the united states attorney office
requesting an opportunity to review the
deceased materials and contending the
documents subject to attorney client
privilege quote should be protected from
the government's review now
this is what this is what trump is
claiming with the special master that
the documents they took
has to do with attorney client privilege
or executive reboot which he does not
have the executive privilege he's not
the president
well they aren't his documents they may
not belong to him right so he cannot
claim it right
exactly
joe biden can because they belong to the
government he holds the office that
holds the executive privilege of the
government
so that is the thing that can happen
yeah but joe biden is not going to do
that apparently it doesn't look like
he's at the white house is even going to
get involved in this case um
besides encourage them to continue to
look into nor should they right like
anything would be seen as a political
move and right fuel well even well even
merrick garland released a memo saying
hey anyone in the department of justice
do not participate in political activity
right do not do and when i say
politicize the [ __ ] out of this merrick
garland's telling people at the
department of justice do not politicize
anything at all in public or in private
just don't do it right because it it can
hurt us it can earn our case
but if you if you really think about
this for a second
because when cohen got his record seized
here
this these records had to do with the
president of the united states writing a
check
to stormy daniels
that was why this that's why this this
raid on cohen was done and they seized
his property
and they asked the very moment that it
was rated and the reason why
is because michael cohen understood that
there was information inside those
records that was probably
attorney-client privilege that couldn't
be viewed by the department of justice
in a way that it's evidence yeah so
that's why he knew immediately they had
to have a special master to figure out a
non-biased party to figure out what was
and what wasn't attorney client
privilege and they did that and still
michael cohen was still and even
michael cohen had a special master
michael cohen pled guilty to a federal
crime he went to prison
he is now a convicted felon because of
it
he even went to congress and showed
congress the goddamn check that
president trump at the time he was
president signed
the shut stormy daniels up
now
if you still are out there and you're in
the comments here talking about a
special master or some [ __ ] or you're on
a twitter thread talking about how he's
gonna get a special master and it's
gonna fix everything
special masters
don't fix anything for the person that
is going to be convicted of a crime yeah
the only thing a special master does if
you're awarded a special master which
the department of justice is so
appropriately pointing out here that if
he wanted one he should ask for one
before right
anyways because they have they legally
have to do this process right well they
have to go through now here's the thing
he goes well two weeks after the fact
either because trump didn't remember
what documents they had or the extent of
them where they were trying to figure
out what their you know strategy was
every day that they didn't do [ __ ] and
he just kept posting on truth social
like i
declassify them and that's that's
legally standing i had a standing order
as soon as i would ever leave the oval
office and i would go to my residence in
the white house
that it was a standing order those
things were declassified that i took
from the oval office right and the same
standing order was there when i moved to
mar-a-lago my residence in in florida
but
in the time that he was like oh this is
unfair and unjust and it's a political
hit from joe biden to the fact of
actually submitting the motion we got
two weeks
and i [ __ ] guarantee as soon as those
documents
hit
because they i mean they had to go
through them probably in a skiff as well
right they had to be in an area to
actually review the documents to say
like all right only a certain amount of
people can have them well they had they
had to give they had to give the taint
team special security clearance to even
look at these documents right
but i i guarantee right out of the gate
they're like we need to review these
documents as soon as possible because we
don't know what's going to happen we
don't know if he'll challenge it if
something else will come about what have
you
but i guarantee they like immediately
went through
and reviewed those documents got the
stuff because
as soon as they go we need you know we
need a special master to go through and
actually say what is or what isn't
allowed but it's too late man they were
they were already through those
documents probably within a matter of
days within that week
that happened on monday i guarantee by
friday they were already through every
document they needed to be through
had him logged documented photographed
you know
obviously
that's kind of the point that the
department of justice is making here
it's like look if you wanted a special
master you should have done it you
should have done it right monday august
8th when the [ __ ] went down when you
released that statement
you could have easily
submitted a motion to say hey we
actually need a special master and we
want to view this independently to know
what is what is executive privilege
and what is not which is none of its
executive privilege none of that [ __ ] is
executive privilege
well and the the other thing too
is that
that the doj is trying to point out here
is that this process happens rather you
get a special master or not we go
through this process and we already went
through this process so now that you're
asking for a special master is is
irrelevant because we've already done it
ourselves you had the right to a special
master but the special master to be
clear does not do anything but make sure
the documents are the evidence that was
collected
is not in some way
related to a cur attorney-client
privilege that has nothing to do with
this case because a turning client
privilege doesn't
doesn't protect crimes so like christina
bob and and
donald trump writing out documents that
they collected about the about
obstructing the investigation of these
documents that's not attorney client
privilege that's not that's part of this
crime that's part of evidence
we've seen it no more clear than in the
january 6 case with with john eastman
where judge carter in california said
they have committed crime here and it
does the attorney-client privilege does
not cover crime when you're criming
together it doesn't work that way and i
see i see someone i see the uh
the a certain someone in the comments
over here talking about what about the
passports what about the passports what
about the [ __ ] passports
they're trying this person that's in the
comments is bringing up like well they
they the the search was too broad they
took everything that was in their
purview they should have taken the
passports here's the problem if you
actually read the documents that were
released last night they were allowed
the search warrant allowed them to seize
all of the stuff that was mixed in with
the documents okay the stuff that they
that the proves that there was intent
because trump had to know where they
were
he had to know oh my passports were in
that box and that box had the documents
it ties him directly to the documents
because they knew
where they were if they were in some
arbitrary box and he's like oh they took
the box whatever
the only reason they would have taken
that box of those contents is because
there was [ __ ] classified top secret
government sei information
inside that box so why well the fact
that you knew that the fact that he
knew where the passport was because
that's where those documents were it
ties him directly
to knowing that he had these documents
so let me let me ask you because this is
a good question this is a good
conversation we're having with the yeah
with the delusional chatter here um in
the in the live chat because here's the
thing
if
if donald trump had his passport
all ready to go with a bunch of
classified documents and we know donald
trump
in reports has taken boxes of documents
across country maybe he was just packing
for a trip to i don't know i don't maybe
maybe saudi arabia maybe maybe russia i
don't know maybe he just had him ready
just in case
he needed to hop on a plane somewhere i
don't know i just want to say so for the
for the the person that's in the
comments for the uh the fake gabe that
is out there oh who comes in who comes
in the chat every day thank you for
boosting this the show commenting
exactly chatting because youtube and
y'all
love you like fake gabe we like to have
him here that way everyone can know what
stupidity actually looks like but if
anyone if anyone out there you see
online tries to say oh well the the
passports prove that it was a broad
overreach of their actual purview right
here's the problem
they had the right to search for the
stuff and the stuff was mixed in with
the classified stuff right
your passports was was mixed in with the
documents that that trump did not own
they were government u.s property and
the fact that he knew that they were
missing
and also lied about it but he knew that
they were missing
proves
that he knew where they were which meant
said they were with the other stuff the
[ __ ] classified stuff right which you
can't you can't separate the two which
because if they're together he would
have known where they were and he would
know what contents they were with which
even better that he points it out as
they give it back like they're like oh
yeah yeah that is in there here we'll
give it back we're we're still going
through all the other crime
yeah we weren't really looking at the
passwords
because they were like we have a filter
that goes through to say like oh is this
relevant nope nope nope
they gave it back special master as it
were not appointed by the court that the
that the doj uses uh minus margie points
out something here which i think is a
very um a very good question
she says she needs to know gabe did you
finish the secret bunker so that we
could make sure that donald trump has a
place
to hide other than melania's uh secure
area that he's not allowed to go in
did we finish the secret bumper bump
bunker so he didn't have a place
47 that were in there this was the 47th
one that we had finished uh 47 for you
know donald trump president number 47.
um
but yeah it is uh it is complete it is
finished it is a safe location um
it's secure is it secure it is is it as
secure as melania's bedroom is from
donald trump it is way more secure like
melania has like a whole biometric
scanner and like a retinal scanner do
you think she has like a hallway that
has like lasers in it and [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah i'm talking about yeah like if you
yeah like if you've ever seen the movie
in traffic like places that fall down
yeah yeah yeah like have you seen
traveling with the with catherine zeta
jones and uh it's been a while yeah well
anyway in that movie where she's like
going through lasers that's what you
would have to do if you weren't actually
allowed to be in there you'd have to
like
go through over blah blah all that stuff
and make sure that you're avoiding the
axes and the saws and the arrows and the
blades do you think she puts like in the
hallway right like let's say it's like
an intersection in the hallway yeah on
the other side
there's no way there's no way she lives
on the side of mar-a-lago that he lives
on right so let's say you're in the
hallway you're in the intersection where
you go down the laser hallway to get to
her bedroom that's very secure from
donald trump to make sure he does not
set foot in that room not because of top
secret documents or hiding stuff she
just does not want him in there but
do you think like at the end of the
other hallway at the other direction
there's like free happy meal and big mac
coupons they're like dangling from
there's i guarantee cheeseburgers and he
runs after the yeah i think
cheeseburgers uh i think
for real uh that property is is very big
right
i wouldn't i wouldn't be surprised if
she had a couple of decoy closets
that she actually hid her real stuff she
was like oh this is actually the real
stuff that i wear and no one's going to
be entered and i'm just going to be able
to come in here and trump was like i'm
going to stash it away in these other
closets and they're just like oh so you
think you think she had fake closets to
distract him from the real closet so she
wouldn't actually go in her bedroom and
that's where he was stashing because he
did say closets yeah there's like 40
there's like 40 some odd bathrooms in
mar-a-lago and so like i have to imagine
there's probably a matching room i don't
know all of those places so no idea well
here here's what i'll tell you is that
uh the melania part of the story is is
very curious now that he brought it up
and now her team her press team is
saying oh watch he doesn't even set foot
near me we have separate bedroom
separate beds i am nowhere near that fat
[ __ ] slump i just think this is an
interesting part of the story and i hope
during the trial we get to see like a
map like the january 6 election when you
meet a map of the white house we get to
see how far away
how far away milan and she'll probably
be in court like no i'm ver husband very
far away husband other side of house
yeah that's like or or she'll be like i
didn't live there i was in new york
right i was at the trump tower
it's all locked away i'm not really sure
but i think that's going to be important
part of the story yeah um everyone is
seizing on this stage stage seems to be
trending because maga really
maga really wants this to be staged
right oh yeah and uh dark amy says dark
amy lin says manga saying this was stage
i bet hillary clinton did it with the
help from hunter biden's laptop i mean
they're just hand feeding these jokes um
to lefty twitter as tankers put it and
i'll repeat myself from the top of the
show
thank you republicans thank you trump
for giving us this none of this stuff
would have come to light or seen the
public eye if they had not challenged
submitted bs motions made [ __ ] uh uh
crazy outlandish accusations about plant
being planted and this being that and
that being that like
they they caused this to happen this
stuff would have never been shown to
anyone
unless it was actually declassified this
is a moment where they overplayed their
hand
thought that the doj was bluffing and
the doj was like all right bet we'll do
it we'll do it we'll release this we'll
unseal it you guys are gonna regret it
they didn't even have to show this photo
i guarantee they probably did not even
have to include this photo oh hell to
the no but they're like no they will
show it they will show it just so you
guys know this isn't [ __ ] made up
well and i mean here's the thing is
these these moglodites these fascists
not semi-fascists they're [ __ ]
america first nazis are trying to stoke
stochastic terrorism is what they're
trying to do and i believe that this
this releasing this on this 40 page
thing is an attempt by the department of
justice to say look
you dummies
out there trying to think that you're
gonna you're gonna create violence and
start violence in the name of trump
you're doing it for all the wrong
reasons and i think that's what this was
was like you've got a choice you have a
mo we are we're at a point in the road
where you can either go left or you can
go right
and you have to choose which one you
want to do one way is the right way and
the other way
is well you're betting on the wrong
horse and you might be in trouble as
well if you decide to take action you
know cause violence
do anything like be the [ __ ]
ricky schiffer
or whatever whatever his name is uh is
this is this the guy that went to
cincinnati with the name he's uh got
himself
over his yeah yeah ricky ricky schiffer
went to cincinnati fbi and one one guns
blazing like [ __ ] star uh like he was
a nationally babbitt type and he ended
up being an ashley babbitt yeah yeah
yeah i mean came with a nail gun of all
things like it's like i'm gonna go
against the government with the [ __ ]
nail gun like that's that's [ __ ] i've
been saying it all week that lindsey
graham and all these other people
calling for riots and [ __ ] and trying to
stoke violence this is really [ __ ]
stupid where are they gonna go to fight
for donald trump if he gets indicted or
convicted where yeah where are they
gonna go they cannot go anywhere i don't
know i don't know where they're gonna i
mean
at this midterm if they think it's
stolen or some [ __ ] what are they gonna
go to every county office there's no
national certification for this midterm
none yeah it doesn't happen there is no
national certification for this election
it is all certified in the counties in
the states
are they going to march to every county
office and take over every this is
really stupid that what they're trying
to do is they're trying to get traitors
elected and the only way to make sure
that they do not take our democracy away
from us is for you to make sure that
they don't get whiny little [ __ ]
traders like this [ __ ] collected why
are people so mean i gotta bring this up
i thought this [ __ ] was i thought it was
fake because i had a while to find it
man i had to search even when you posted
that it's real i'm like i still i can't
believe it i gotta go find it when i
went into the app the only way i could
find it was by searching why are people
so mean question mark
in the actual the search bar i couldn't
find on his profile like throughout the
whole day it was it was it was this he
was tweeting he was he was well he was
reposting a lot of [ __ ] like he was on a
tie he's like he was posting a cash link
here and this and that like he it was
insane but i had to when after i saw
brian tyler cohen posted i was like wait
this is really real hold on hold on hold
hold the phone
right so i went into the app and i was
like it's not here i'm all the way into
yesterday
and i don't see anything like i don't
see anything for august it's hard it was
hard to find i had to certainly it took
me a while to find it which i was like
why is this being suppressed
you know well like why why is this post
being hidden from people well because he
posted it
i mean
you're uh you're just a little [ __ ] is
what i i've also made through i made
sure to go through uh his recent posts
and just comment with the photo that was
taken from the fbi and posted last night
so i just went through and i just with
no context
i just commented the photo on it on
probably like ten different uh posts
that he had on youtube you're gonna get
banned over there they definitely want
to read i i had a message
i had a message the other day that i
posted on truth social really quickly i
posted a message that said
um
uh what did they say
what you're finding here steve says tony
did a screenshot post yeah i screenshot
it i got you from the from the fraud
social i got a screenshot so i posted
three days ago i said it was in a
comment uh it was a it was a response to
donald trump jr
and i said your dad sold government
secrets and i said oh you're upset that
your daddy trump is a traitor best of
luck lol there there is nothing
there is i did not swear
i didn't say i didn't know
i didn't do anything as a creator
on here
i look at my like alerts and it was like
sensitive content this content made me
not suitable for all audiences and i was
like wait what did i post that was
sensitive and i click it and it says oh
you're upset that your daddy trump is a
traitor best of luck lol and then of
course i have people and they're like
get away troll leave you're not welcome
here
so
you mean we're censoring you and
canceling you get this question my
speech is
my speech my question for you gabe is
why are you so mean
why
why you know you so
mean i uh
i was asked that yesterday and i i think
my response was i tend to be very mean
to traitors yeah and fascists nazis
fascists i do not like them that is that
is
there not anywhere not in the house not
not not with a mouse not in a box not
with a box this could be a whole yeah
you know we should do that yeah we
should do that maybe we should um
yeah why not why not well you know there
is some true social news
and i think we missed yesterday that
it's coming back around it was the
google play did we cover the google play
thing yesterday no um
yesterday
right that that because one of the one
of the news one of the news stories was
that um true social not only are they up
to their eyeballs in debt but they
didn't get their trademark yeah but
yesterday after the bad news that they
didn't get their trademark um it was
announced that not only will they not
get their trademark
google play won't not play ball with
them in their app store yeah and this is
hoping for the reason that true social
is a [ __ ] uh a [ __ ] swamp over
there right it's the reason why google
won't put them on their store the thing
to know here
is that
google play
is a relatively easy kind of marketplace
to get into there's not a lot of it's
easier than apple i mean oh way easier
apple is way more strict um in terms of
selling the apple store because that's
right right so i don't know exactly what
happened at least when they first got
approved but i think what's happening
now is google play has seen what has
been posted ricky schiffer threatening
fbi lives that he's going to kill them
he's going to go to the fbi building in
cincinnati he's going to go shoot up the
place with the [ __ ] nail gun
now that google
has seen this stuff because when they
got approved to the apple store that was
done initially they had just been going
right this was before this is before the
platform was even launched yeah apple
was like okay this is just a social
network there's nothing wrong here
because it was almost an exact copy an
exact copy of twitter oh yeah no it is
so they probably figured that their
moderation would be very simple right
right right right they did have a hiccup
in the beginning and then they fixed it
and they're like great you've been
approved right yeah because you're
talking about mac and march when they
released it and it it wouldn't work so
they're like oh well we're gonna have to
wait and you you waited on the list you
were like nine hundred and yeah it was
in thousand i don't believe that list
was real but that's uh you know that was
my own kind of right you were like 12th
in line yeah i was research i was
digging into yeah there were four other
people borrowing yeah yeah there weren't
a lot of people i mean even today
they're you know
even the verified accounts aren't active
like the only people that are the most
active people on the verified side are
donald trump donald trump jr but even
the other ones that makes that bring
rock hasn't posted in months but that
brings up a good point is that was one
of google play's reasons it's like hey
you have verified accounts on here
dozens of verified accounts that you're
boosting in the algorithm that is
pushing dangerous information and these
threads have tons of threats on them and
that was one of the reasons yeah right
and so that's the big reason is like now
because initially they were like all
right great you got approved in the
other verifying terrorists i mean right
and they they got approved in the apple
store because there wasn't anything to
be worried about it was just another
social network that yes looked a copycat
version of twitter but that's not
illegal you know so uh even though it's
apparent that they stole their stuff and
they just renamed it to be truths
instead of tweets and whatever
but
now that there's been time because
remember or i just want people to know
that this wasn't like oh they were part
of the google play store and they were
taken down they have never been allowed
in since they launched they promised
that they were going to launch with the
apple uh with the google play store they
didn't have the code right they kept
going back and forth with the google
play store to figure out what they
needed to do
in between that time and now
they have realized that oh [ __ ] there's
no moderation people could say whatever
the [ __ ] they want on here they can
threaten people talk about their
moderating when
when i call someone a traitor or when i
say you are
selling secrets or like you had you
stole secrets or whatever it is i get i
get flagged and my account gets
suppressed in terms of my posts you know
what you should do gabe you should hire
an attorney to protect to
tell the truth about you getting
suppressed um i don't know you know yeah
have you seen it did you see this ad for
this new attorney i did
like a hell of a deal yeah 180 184 easy
payments of
99.99 jim trustee well you must trust
him because
the website is trusting me i'm jim
trustee yeah um one 1-800 tv lawyer this
sounds like a good deal i've seen on tv
uh lawyer this is who i would want to
hire um you definitely did not make this
right not at all definitely didn't make
it wasn't me i don't know why i would
have made it
the other funny thing is that uh so if
anyone knows toby morton right uh he's a
writer and uh comedian he's worked on
south park uh but he's now and he's
worked on he's worked on lauren bobert
for a long time it's not just her right
it's devin nunes mccarthy so he has a
whole list if you go check his out his
stuff you know i think it's just
tobymorton.com
um
you can find his content oh nope nope we
can't go there it's somewhere else but
if you look at like the real lone bow
bird and you look up you know kevin
mccarthy he makes all of these satirical
sites right that are of four like that
are pro
uh these candidates right but ends up
being uh revealing to have news articles
and photos and so on and so forth that
actually shows them in their true light
as
fascists or seditionists or traitors or
whatever it might be
and so we
he and i are now working on making he
bought he after he saw this he bought
jimtrusty.com
oh [ __ ]
and so now that guy didn't own that
that's funny no no no
so we bought uh he he bought
jimtrusty.com and so i will probably end
up making a video as jim trustee but
he's going to put together a little
landing page
uh
for this website well speaking of satire
oh boy ollie teaks did some satire and
speaking of traders who hate to be
called trade they're really they're
really upset when you call them traders
we watch this video the other day do you
recognize these people in this now we
were really confused about who this guy
was in the middle of the other he looks
very the guy
the guy who is this guy who is this guy
though this is
this is uh stephen miller
with oh
he's got a nice he's got a nice uh uh
rug here yeah yeah he got a pretty good
haircut
thanks to thanks to being um you know he
he lives off his parents money right
on their selfies he's still in their
t-mobile plan well you know that happens
that's how you obstruct justices be on
your live in your parents basement and
be on their their his excuse was we
can't we can't give you these these
phone rings because they're my mommy
yeah they're you're my mommy's my mom
makes these clients
my mom my mom was calling the president
and and planning this coup that's what
was happening but my mama said but my
mama charlie kirk another mama's boy
here oh yeah it seems like his head is
getting bigger gabe yeah it's getting
pretty big going on let's let's watch
and see how big his head's getting you
have to remain peaceful on our side but
i do think that if they're going to
escalate the language then game on like
okay if you're going to call us a bunch
of fascists we're not going to take that
anymore you're the fascist joe biden and
there's other words we could use as well
we're not going to oh my god paul
changed this video he didn't change
anything about it but but charlie had or
charlie kirk's head is just a smidge
bigger not really that much bigger yeah
it's a tiny bit tiny bit bigger like
what i put here on stephen miller and it
makes you [ __ ] hilarious he puts he
puts uh charlie kirk's hair on his head
which is what that is yeah that's
charlie kirk's hair oh okay so i thought
it looked like a shitty haircut i'm like
yeah i don't know oh you could at least
gave him a decent america it's charlie
kirk and then you've got that kurt dario
kurt sphincter
uh who's in the middle who's like uh uh
uh yeah he was trying to figure out this
by the way that guy kurt if anyone's
seen his [ __ ] on twitter he's just a
right-wing
wannabe
uh
just nut job like the guy picks on women
make it makes fun of uh you know
fat phobic comments
uh homophobic comments the guy is is
terrible he is a terrible
person hence why we called him yesterday
kurt sphincter sphincter did you see
that dark brandon made an appearance of
the damn oh my god
i did randomly i did i did see it there
was a summoning that happened yeah well
you know that that the first um
dark brandon uh video the summoning that
we saw i don't know it was last week
yeah it was so popular we were really
searching for a new one this is the one
that happened was this yesterday jesus
christ this week yesterday seems like a
million years ago in news and news time
oh i mean after that so much [ __ ] after
that stuff dropped it right at night it
was like
five weeks worth of news in like two
seconds but here is dark brandon at the
at a rally here and he's talking about
he's talking about traitors here let's
listen you can't be pro-law enforcement
and pro-insurrection
you can't be a part of law and order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots
you can't do it
oh dark brandon man he's had it he's at
it it is i mean he's he's stating fact
you cannot be one and the other at the
same time you can't be pro-democracy you
cannot pro-law enforcement in
pro-insurrection right like you cannot
do that you cannot be for law
enforcement
but then attack the people who were
trying to uh
guard the capitol and be and and defend
the people who are attacking those
officers right i thought you were pro
police wow [ __ ]
defund the fbi well here's the thing
tomorrow apparently joe biden is going
to make a speech
in prime time about the uh the soul of
our country and to try to push back on
this fascism as he so well pointed out
the other day i don't think he actually
pointed out very well he just called
amer first nazis instead of
semi-fascists they're not
semi-passionate they're full-on
they're full-on [ __ ] nazis um but
he's going to be giving a speech and i
think we're going to carry this thing on
the midas touch network um live so stay
tuned here at the tony michaels podcast
um tomorrow um we'll be streaming i
think we're going to be streaming this
live we're going to figure it out today
to get you guys some coverage of the
speech from joe biden so after you're
done here today go follow over on minus
touch network subscribe to their channel
as well but again while you're here
don't forget to subscribe here at the
tony michael's podcast we've got a lot
of new listeners here today you can also
download every single one of our
episodes on apple spotify google all
your favorite directories leave us a
great review why you're subscribing
there at that directory speaking of law
enforcement gabe fake law enforcement
herschel walker appears in the news
again with a clip
did you see the whole he [ __ ] put out
a picture of him being an honorary
sheriff or some [ __ ] oh yeah he's like
oh i got you got you warnock see i am a
fake law enforcement officer
i saw someone post a photo in in
response to that and it was like those
little airline wings that you get when
you like fly on there's like a little
kid and they're like oh yeah and they
said uh herschel walker's also gonna
tell us he's also
a pilot right well i mean when you're a
kid remember they used to give like when
you go to like
the fairs they have the the the fire
department was there where you could
right yeah the fire truck and they give
you the the plastic hat that said
firefighter on it and then and then the
police were there and they would give
you a fake badge that said you're
honorary police that's literally what he
has is well that's like one of those
it's like those stickers that people buy
like you know uh you ever seen the
stickers on the back of a of a truck or
a car which is you know they say they're
like oh i'm a proud donor of like this
local law enforcement you know
you know obviously an attempt to be like
hey if i get pulled over just know i'm
[ __ ] i'm back the blue i'm with you
guys wink
i mean other than the actual other than
actual justice where they're trying to
sniff out traders and prospects yeah
traders in our country but that's all
that that's
just it's just a sticker that he paid
for or some little some little some
little card that they printed out and he
signed it at the police department he's
a real fake sheriff's deputy okay no no
no no he's really a fake one okay i
don't believe the real fake thing let's
listen here's more real fake [ __ ] from
herschel walker he's terrified to
actually debate warnock because warnock
will absolutely he knows remember a
losing proposition remember they had a
debate that was planned for thursday and
he was like well no one's gonna watch
he's faking that who's backing out who's
backing out of that one is it warnock no
it's hershey
walker walker is walking away you mean
walker is walker's the one who's backing
out of a debate but let's listen to this
video because that's not how he puts it
i've always went out and worked you know
i'm gonna say i'm always gonna be
transparent with him because i always
have been i'm not gonna hide i'm gonna
hire like center why not and what i
would say to senator why not is where
you at scaredy cat debate me october 14
savannah georgia in front of our
audience and let's let the people see
and i think you guys love that too
oh this guy why does he keep saying the
word transparency he says that word like
i mean you know the scene from the
princess brian we talked about all the
time like yeah yeah using that word i
don't think you know what that word
means right right yeah
but
he just says yeah he just says
walker right the the reason he's now
doubling down on the fact he's like
where are you at scaredy cat which i
guarantee he spent all morning
trying to get that line to be like all
right just like lauren bobert the other
day when she was like this lesbian dance
theory the they come in prepared and i'm
not saying any of the possibilities
there's outright trump's speech oh yeah
don't do this
like dance
yeah he's like lieutenant corporal lance
corporal like you know it's those things
where they they plan to say these things
and they [ __ ] it up or they they plan it
and it's so
so staged and rehearsed that doesn't
come across right but rem like keep in
mind that even it was like last week or
a week and a half ago herschel walker
was like i'm not doing the debate
because people which by the way was
scheduled for a thursday
or still is scheduled for thursday i
don't know what october 14th is now but
uh is scheduled for not going though
yeah and he was like no one's going to
watch it because everyone is going to be
watching sunday night football the the
debate isn't for a sunday it's for a
thursday
it's well dave they play sunday night
football on thursday every once in a
while yeah well come on man my bad i
think he's saying thursday night
football surely he's just he's just got
he's got
he's kicking in and he can't determine
i don't know
i don't know that's given a lot of
benefit i'm just trying to help him out
here jesus christ the best i can do the
best i can do uh looks like uh turley is
trending okay so sorry october the 14th
is now a friday so
oh it's a friday now it's a friday so
they might have switched it from
whenever there is no football there is
no uh nfl football on so no one can say
that football is an issue right well i
doubt he's gonna actually
show up um jonathan turley is trending
here um which is um it could be
significant i'm not sure why but let's
let's read why attorney and george
washington university law professor
which why the hell is he still a law
professor jonathan turley weighs in on
the new doj filing regarding the top
secret documents allegedly being kept at
allegedly what the [ __ ] do you mean
allegedly there's no allegedly we now
know it twitter get the [ __ ] out of here
with this allegedly [ __ ] we don't need
to see the world this is one of those
things that i would recommend for all
republicans like you should you should
learn by now
you should learn by now
that you need to shut the [ __ ] up when
it comes to mar-a-lago and this fbi
search because here's the thing
anytime well you know what actually
don't don't shut the [ __ ] up sorry just
listen to what i said keep talking keep
doing what you're doing keep challenging
do not shut the [ __ ] up keep talking
that's those those are that is that is
actually my recommendation for all
republicans out there just keep talking
well tim miller points out george
washington and he's talking about the
university should transfer turley to the
creative writing department this is some
funny [ __ ] um i'm not sure i'm not sure
exactly what it says we're going to read
it as soon as i give i'm going to give
um
tim credit here
and then we're going to go to the uh so
tim thanks for the uh the commentary
there oh he even post the picture on
jonathan jonathan turley.org at least
if you're gonna write fiction if you're
gonna write fiction you gotta add a
little color and you know substance so
people can actually imagine the
surrounding the environment they're in i
love that it's dot org though that his
website that he secured is jonathan
turley.org
jonathan turley here says notably this
finally includes this picture which is
being widely distributed yeah that was
their intention yeah for the american
people to see that yes it's not alleged
that there's top secret documents it's
not allegedly
here is the evidence they were there
dummy no it's not also
it's
leaving an obviously misleading
impression no
this is not this you can clearly see
a a little folded sign that says 2a
trump did not have 2a on the ground
these are documents or the measuring
tape right do you think trump is like oh
i got to measure that this is actually
11 by 14 legal legal paper oh this is
legal size this fit in between the time
magazine frames or not it is not this is
not i don't know anyone
that looked at this and thought
oh this is
this is how they found it now maybe
knowing trump's history and his actual
past behavior of how he actually has his
uh
his office in new york
you might be able to look and be like
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if the ship
was all over the ground
but this is just laying out within the
area that they're given to take a photo
to show here are the documents we found
in this location
here's a little sign to say this how
this is the you know evidence exhibit
whatever
2a and then laying out to be like here
are as many classified sci top secret
documents that we can show and layer
them to be like it wasn't just one it's
not just a stack this gives you an idea
of what we actually found well let me
let me read the rest of jonathan trader
i mean turley's uh tweeter he says it
can however leave and
obviously misleading impression that
secret documents were strewn over the
floor when this appears to be the work
of fbi agents now so he's saying what
you're saying but here's the thing
now here's the thing gabe here's the
thing gabe
if you think about this
if this
is
either a
or two a whichever way you look at it
yeah if this is a that donald trump had
these documents laying out like this
or b the fbi putting them out so they
could take a picture of it wouldn't you
think that in either case either case
that someone is laying these documents
out to take pictures of them
okay i think this is very important i
think i think i messaged you this last
night i said
it looks like someone put them out to
take pictures on them
meaning either the fbi
was taking pictures of where they were
at and then wanted to take them out
because you can't see documents like in
a folder right
yeah out a filing cabinet you wouldn't
get a good idea of what the hell was in
there i mean you would see that there's
just also you're like oh it looks like a
bunch of folders but you're like what
are these folders right so either a
which could be the case
that donald trump laid these out all
over the floor
or b the fbi had to lay them out on the
floor to take a picture either way it
looks like
it looks like it was set up
to take a picture of those documents for
proof or to give them to somebody i
would imagine that if it's the doj
taking pictures for evidence if donald
trump was taking a picture who do you
think he was giving that to right so i
think that's the questions that should
be asked not not
not that oh they're trying to set him up
what do you mean set him up what are you
talking about setting him up because
they pulled the documents out that he
had that he's not supposed to have and
take a picture as evidence that he had
him there i mean jesus this [ __ ]
carpet man yeah can we talk about i mean
i know these documents is very bad well
look it's really bad that this guy stole
these documents it's even worse that
he's obstructing
an investigation there but let me the
real crime tonight the real crime a real
crime is this motherfucker's carpet i'm
dead serious this [ __ ] carpet is
gaudy and stupid as [ __ ] i mean the
worst hotels in the world the worst
hotels in the world
don't have as gaudy a carpet as this let
me pull this picture back up let me find
it here god damn it i lost it i want to
i want to point this out to everybody
here that this [ __ ] carpet is some
just i mean doesn't this just stink of
just like a roach motel
oh yeah carpet yeah yeah no no like it
is
it's posted when i posted a photo uh
last week a photo that was taken in
april of 1967 of the pine hall room
right yeah
yeah we had it on the show yeah people
were like oh no no this i cause i i
posted it later on there in the day and
people were like oh no no a lot has
changed no a lot of mar-a-lago has not
changed because she's seen the [ __ ]
cheap [ __ ] yeah it's mar-a-lago
is like the epitome of the gilded age
it's a [ __ ] like gold paint plastered
all over the place
carpets and rugs like this it doesn't
add anything you know especially
especially when you're like oh melania
redecorated and they redesigned this and
by the way trump also did not like the
redecoration that was done by melania
well yeah because it cost him money that
he needs to grift other people you know
he needs money to keep this laundering
machine going and he needs to keep it
going here and really honestly it's just
like any of the trump trump property
it's a [ __ ] dump it's a [ __ ] dump
and really honestly to believe that this
[ __ ] [ __ ] was securing these
documents somehow better than the
government would secure them it's really
someone's gonna say not surprising i'm
gonna i'm gonna call it right now
someone on there is gonna say that this
was a set
created by george soros
and it's in hollywood i can go down the
street
i'm just saying i'm just saying i
guarantee someone on the right if not on
true social because they're actually
they're dropping uh i just saw some
stuff that was about q on true social
and donald trump was reached well
of course he was yeah i mean you mean
currently he's on there freaking out
not right now but it was like two days
ago or yesterday but what i will say is
like i guarantee someone on the right
someone [ __ ] on the right was like
how do we know this wasn't staged how do
we know this weren't photos taken on a
set is that even the real carpet or rug
of donald trump's mar-a-lago home
well here's what i'll tell you wait just
wait gabe that story is cute with a cue
it is really cute
a story that you're coming up with there
you should you should spread that around
on the internet see how far it goes
everybody don't forget to come back here
tomorrow because we are here every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and we
simulcast from the minus touch facebook
page don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel while you're here you
don't want to miss a thing you don't
want to miss an episode because you can
also download every single episode on
your favorite directory spotify google
apple
where every we're on google we're not
like true social you can
we don't have content that is inciting
violence right no causing harm or
threatening harm we just point out the
fascists so you know who they are so you
can save your democracy so you can
engage in your democracy support
pro-democracy speech everywhere if you
want to support it here go to
support.tonymichaelspod.com or you can
get the qr code down at the bottom
and tomorrow
yeah and tomorrow yeah we have we have a
poll coming out that's right which will
allow you to participate in democracy
that's right vote for the bonehead
of the week bone end of the week go to
wow there are some good
good candidates this week christina bob
is in there this this [ __ ] truthy guy
or truly guy or whatever who is this guy
she's trusty trusty guy that's him
that's him trusty truly who knows
oh boy it's going to be a hell of a
bonehead of the week it's gonna be a
great week for american democracy folks
don't let up lean into democracy
politicize every single one of these
issues and come here every single day
for two full hours to know how to
politicize every [ __ ] one of them
every single one of them until tomorrow
same time same place surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking